This has gone along quite enough!
Sweden has been a peaceful country!
But not anymore!
Now of course,
I would never incite violence towards T-Series.
But, in a hypothetical scenario...
You versus me. Hua cha cha cha cha cha cha cha!
I'm gonna show how that would look like.
I'm just gonna show you guys just how confident I feel in fighting T-Series.
So, there's a new level on this game...
called Crab.
That's right, Crab.
That's cause T-Series...
I know that they are crab people.
And I'm here to demonstrate.
God damn crab people...
I'm not racist of course, but I freaking hate crab people.
Okay.
Oh my God.
I have entered their base.
What are...
Nunchucks!
*angelic music plays*
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOH
*smack sound*
Combo!
That's what I'm talking about!
*multiple smack sounds*
You want some? You get some.
*grunt*
Oh, shoot...
(felix going sicko mode rare footage!)
lets go for the knees! GAHAWHah
get em
get those [knees boi]
what do you want
𝕗𝕚𝕟𝕖
,.-~*¨¯¨*·~-.¸-(_ you know what _)-,.-~*¨¯¨*·~-.¸
fiຖē fiຖē, ITS OK, i'๓ ຖ໐t ງ໐iຖງ t໐ fiງht ฯ໐น
I ᒍᑌᔕT ᑕᗩᗰE TO ᔕEᑎᗪ ᗩ ᗰEᔕᔕᗩGE
And I never show mercy [red eye flares]
Come Here
[Sub 2 PewDiePie] *ExTrEmE FiGhT ScEnE*
AHHHHHHHH
Ahh
*Happiness Noises*
This is my weapon now
*again EPIC FIGHT SCENE*
DAMN IT
ka Fuf
*Breathing Noises*
*Game Voice* : persistence is a thing few fighters have
*Game Voice* : Show us you are Ready to die
*Game Voice* : Salute me
*Sicko Mode*
Kawaiiiiii *0w0*
huha hahaha
Oh ,There we got a new weapon
I've been waiting for these
*gasps*
My Japanese blades
Nihongo Katana
Forgive me, but I must all out  *Angel noises*
While you guys play Minecraft  *Angel Noises*
I study the blade
*War Drum Beats*
*screeching metal noises*
*EpIc FiGhT ScEnE*
[get those arms boi]
[Sub 2 Pewds Or This will Happen to you, if you are already subbed ignore this]
Swedish Strategy
Everyday Son
Honga
I'm the crab now
Bih
T- S E R I E S  is gonna be like this
[Get Those Knees Pewds]
Who did that?
[get those arms boi]
oh Fu*k I Fu*kin hate how just one guy shows up out of no where and kills you
*Game Voice* : This weapon will hurt you
oh I got a new weapon
any weapon will take it T- S E R I E S
Where's the weapon then
Jesus Christ
Where's the weapon
WHERE
*wolverine blades show up*
HUUH
WOAH
HOH
HMM
AHH
That is so cool
Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha
T-S E R I E S
YOU DON'T KNOW MY REAL POWER
*wolverine fight scene by Pewds*
*Shows the no-no finger accidentally*
YOUU
Uh HAHAHAHA
IMMA SCRATCH UP N I P P L E S BI*CH
Come here
NOO
*Scratches That Guy's B UTT
LISTEN TO ME  x2
LISTEN TO ME YOU SICK
YOU'RE SICK AND YOU NEED AMPUTATE
Can't Say Anything
OH GOD
*Sonic noises*
HUH
DON'T THINK SO BUDDY
THIS IS SWEDEN
That was cool
That was definitely cool
I SAID DON'T WAVE
THATS WHAT I'M TALKIN' ABOUT
*Game voice* : There are many left to kill
YEAH yeah bring them , bring 'em
WHAT IS THAT
Ohh Okay I got it
I got it
It's a frisbee
And a FREAKIN' SWORD
What the hell
If anyone comes this near
I'm Gonna use the DEADLY Frisbee
HUH
*BRUH MOMENT*
Are you kidding me?
Don't make me use frisbee
*BOOMERANG MOMENT*
THE GOD DAMN FRISBEE SUCKS
DON'T MAKE ME USE THE FIRSBEE
*BRUH*
GOD * Struggle noises*
NOOO FISBEE
YOU KNOW WHAT I DON'T NEED ANYTHING ELSE
BRING IT
BRING HIM
OHHH MY GOD
OHH GOD
I never fought a fu*kin CRAB before
The Final Battle
PewDiePIe Versus T- S E R I E S
They are claiming crabs
PETA is gonna be so mad
Okay bring it
God he is so tiny
Oh God that's a CRAB Attack
I'm just Studying my opponent
OH GOD
HO
*CRAB BATTLE INTENSIFIES*
GO AWAY COLLAB(CRAB)
GO AWAY THIS IS NOT PERSONAL
IT AIN'T PERSONAL
YES I GOT HIS CLAW
NOW HIS OTHER CLAW
[GET HIS CLAW PEWDS]
WE FIGHT THIS CLAW
YES
HAHAHAHA
*breaths*
Hah hahhaha
AHH
hahaha
Come here
NO come here
come here
Daddy wants a hug
Daddy wants a HUUUG
COME HERE
COME HERE I SAID
FU*K OFF YOU BI**
* BREATHING* *RESTORING ENERGY*
PAW
[PUNCH THE SH1T OUT PEWDS]
*gasping*
AH
he is tryna' Run
he's tryna' run
come, come here
come here
YOU KILLED HIM
HOW COULD YOU
HE WAS JUST A BAD-BAD
AHHHHHHH
*BATTLE INTENSIFIES*
DON'T
*grunts*
*Something japanese *
*BATTLE INTENSIFIED*
OH GAWD
*CRAB VERSUS PEWDS*
this is disgusting
I LOVE YOU *kisses*[don't tell marzia]
but we have to be like this
I'm sorry
you're not good enough
[crab goes sicko mode ]
*Game voice* : Raise your hands , Victory is yours
"Not until it stops breathing" - pewds 2k19
okay , I guees that was it
That is it for the crabs , I wanted more crabs
are you kidding me?
*Game voice* : This is a real weapon
WHAT?
YESSS
YEESSSSSS
AHHH
HAHAHAHAHAHA
HAHA HAAH
I'M THE CRAB KING
CRAB KING , KRAB KING
KRAB KING
they will feed off your n i p p l e s
they will feed off them
ahhh
ha hahaha
*breaths*
Come here
urghhhh ahhhhh
*Heavy breathing*
ahhhh
CRAB
king
*Punch*
OHH I can hold the weapon as the crab king
*casual fights with pewds*
*Game voice* : Take up your weapon and salute
Oh I'm Giant
oh my god
HAHAHA
CRAB KING
GAWH HAHAHAHA
*wheezes*
AH HAHA
OHHH ITS LIKE
PLUCKING PETALS OF A FLOWER
DOES HE LOVE ME
DOES HE LOVE ME NAWT
OHHHHHHH
*PEWD beeps*
Oh what you gonna do
uhh GOOD MOVE
good move
CRAB KING
That's Right Dance for CRAB KING
okay, alright punch me as hard as you can
OH wow that was really good
lemme just
ohhh  ohhhh
ohh
oopsie
OOPSIIIIEEEEE
hey come here
arrgghh I wanted to get a HUG
oh look he dropped a little weapon
look at this cute little weapon
oh he is still alive over there
oh you dropped your foot
*laughs*
you dropped your little foot
lemme just get that for you
CRAB King is very generous you know
lets just get you little footie
hey buddy
hey buddy how you doin'
isn't that your foot
here put it back on
let me put it back on
stop , stop
I'm gonna have
there we go
Right back on
just thankful
CRAB KING
WELL WELL WELL
I've been playing Gorn
god damn look at my face
hope you guys enjoy this episode ( yes , we did)
and T-S E R I E S   I hope I explain myself
I hope I made Myself Clear
CRAB KING 4 LYF
CRAB KING RULZ
ALL  H A I L  CRAB KING
See you guys next time , byeeee
[SUB 2 PEWDIEPIE IF You are tired of this or if not then also sub to pewds]
PLAY THIS GAME ,THIS GAME IS EPIC , YOU GUYS SHOULD TRY THIS GAME. 5 STARS
EDITORS' (BRAD1 AND SIVE 1) AND TRANSLATORS' Lives matter too , CHECK OUT THEIR CHANNELS TOO